Hello, everybody. It is the 28th of November, 2018. Sure, everybody just had a wonderful, I hope everybody
said a wonderful thanksgiving, much to be thankful for and preparing for Christmas now. So today,
Zoom call, we're going to talk, talk, I'm going to chat briefly on this issue of copper and how it relates
to cancers and what we can do about it. So there is a phenomena, there is much data out there of
copper's relationship to cancer because copper is so, is it an important, very essential element
in growth. It is known that as we age, our copper concentration goes down and part of the
belief in that is that we don't need as much copper as we age. Copper is essential with growth
and cell replication. It's important for that. And you can measure your copper levels in your blood.
Typically, they're measured in a blood test that also measures zinc. So let's talk about that.
We're not going to go through all these different slides, but there's a few that we want to talk about,
this one in particular. So when we measure a person's copper level, we typically measure their copper
zinc ratio. And I've done that at a number of you, and we can plug that at all of you if you want,
we just have to send you a kit that is a blood, there's two ways to do it. You can do it through a
blood draw, and you can do it through a finger prick. So the finger prick is where you put drops of blood
on a little dot, on a paper. That can be kind of a pain if you're not, if you're a good clotter
because you might have to prick yourself multiple times to get the dot filled with blood.
Those are, that's called a blood spot test. And there's a lab that we use that does a blood spot
copper zinc ratio test. And it gives us a valuable data. And there's numerous studies. Here's just some
links to some of the studies where this is coming from right out at the bottom of the slide here.
But the numerous studies show that many people, not all cancer patients, but many people with cancer,
have an increased copper to zinc ratio, meaning that their copper levels are higher than
that should be compared to the zinc levels. And another thing that you can measure also is called
your CP. That's called your seruloplasm. The seruloplasm is your copper transporter. So the copper
transporter could also be elevated in cancer patients. So cancer patients with elevated serum,
that's your blood copper or seruloplasm, can correlate with tumor burden. So what did that
term tumor burden means in increase in tumor growth? So this is another way you're talking about,
are there ways to know that I'm getting better or know if I'm getting worse? Well, what is an IVG test?
What is obviously your symptoms? What is if you have different blood markers like a CEA-125 or
different tumor markers or a prostate PSA antigen that's revealing that it's rising or falling,
that can tell us if we're getting better or maybe getting worse. So we can look at those. We can
do CT scans, MRIs, but we can also look at things like your copper zinc ratio and your seruloplasm
levels. These would be considered as primary things to see if our burden is getting worse or not,
but it can be a good picture because it's something that you could actually take action on to drop
copper levels. So why would copper levels go up in cancer patients when the cancer is growing? And
that is because copper is essential for cell replication. So if we could drop copper levels down,
then we can hinder cell replication. This is why we don't want to put people on supplements that have
a lot of copper in them. Whereas there are a lot of supplements on the market that have copper in
them because if you don't have cancer, copper is good for you and you want to be able to heal quickly
and you want, especially if you're working out and breaking down muscle because you're lifting
weights and doing all this work, you want cells to replicate and muscles to grow and build up.
So there's going to be a call and a need for copper. But when we're dealing with cancer,
we don't want elevated copper levels. So we want to do things to get rid of copper.
Oh, we're not going to go over some of these detailed slides. This shows what copper does in the
metabolic pathway. We don't want to go too much into that, but we're going to come back to that slide.
But here's how we would get rid of excess copper. Now, we already have numerous patients,
number of you might be taking a copper homeyopath right now. So a homeyopath is a frequency of copper
in a dropper form. So it's a dropper that you're putting under your tongue and that's helping your
body recognize and help your body rid copper excess copper out of your body. There's also specific
nutrition that could help chelate copper out of your body. Syllodrol was known to help chelate
copper. Chubate and phobic acid is known to chelate copper. IP-6 can chelate copper. EDTA and DMSO
are stronger chelators that chelate a lot of heavy metals. Well, so do all these things here chelate
heavy metals too. And copper is a metal. So we want to use those type of chelators to pull out.
Not out here is modified citrus pectin. That could also be a good chelator of copper. So if you're on
any of the citrus pectin, the MCP synergy or the pectusol C, that is a good chelator of copper as well.
So those are good things to help pull copper out of your body. How do we how are we exposed to copper?
We'll go back to this slide. Copper is in naturally occurring in a lot of our foods.
So your vegetables that you eat do have copper in it. So you are going to be exposed to
good food-based sources of copper in good foods like vegetables. Still, we don't want excess copper
regardless of whether it's coming from a good source or a bad source. Here's some bad sources of copper.
There could be in our water, elemental copper in our water, copper pipes. You could have water in
your copper, in your water from your copper pipes. You're using copper cookware, copper pots.
And it can be in a lot of pesticides and things like that as well. So there's some, those are elemental
sources of copper that aren't really beneficial for your body and they can stimulate excess growth
as well. So one of the things that we use a lot in our office is it's opposing nutrient or it's
opposing metal because zinc is a metal too. Zinc balances copper. So remember, what did we look for when
we look at a person's blood levels if they have excess copper? They're going to have diminished zinc.
So that copper to zinc ratio was going to be elevated. That means they're going to have excess
amounts of copper and decreased amounts of zinc. So if we added zinc to our diet, would that be enough?
Not necessarily just adding zinc. You still want to do the key layers as well. But adding zinc
would be beneficial. How do we get zinc into the tumor? That's the difficult thing.
Without injecting it right into the tumor, how do we get it into the tumor? And that's where we came
up with that zinc DMSO spray that many of you are caking. So this is again to remind you why you're
doing that. Why am I spray this zinc DMSO spray on my body? I forget to do that. I haven't done that
for a few weeks. Well, this is just a healthy reminder. The reason why you're doing that is to drive
the zinc into the cancer to help offset those high levels of copper and help push that copper out
into the blood. So your body could get rid of it. Your liver could get rid of it. If you're taking
chelate agents that could grab onto it and pull it out of your body. So we want to increase our
zinc levels to help decrease our copper levels. Okay. So I'm going to open us up for questions
and unmute you. So we'll take a few questions and I forgot I have to ask you a question that I
got on email too. So any questions out there? Yeah, this is Ken Rosentrade from Anchorage, Alaska.
Yes. This is probably a weird question, but I've noticed the last three months that
here's my question. So is there ever an example of the rife machine creating insomnia?
Can the rife machine create insomnia? Absolutely. It could. So anything could wake you up, right? So if
you are a real light sleeper, like I'm a super light sleeper, I was the one that first woke up with
all our kids. I could hear them roll over and bad. It seemed like. And the rife machine, while I
answer this, I'm going to mute everybody. We're getting some feedback. So when we, anything that is
going to be a light in your room can increase your, it could decrease your ability to stay sleepy.
So that is, that is an issue with some people. If you cover it up, make sure. So some of my fixes for
that would be to try to keep it underneath your blanket. Put the machine itself farther away from the
bed and cover it up some way. We can get extension wires. So right now, I think the wires from the
bulb to the machine. I don't know, maybe our six, eight feet long. We've had a couple people that we've
got extensor extension wires from true rife for them that went another 10 feet so that they could
put the machine in the closet and close the closet door. And they would hear less of the sound from that
because many times it's the sound. So there, you're going to have to play with some ways to help
decrease the any whatever it is that's keeping you awake. And it's not the frequencies that are
going to keep you awake because there's, there really isn't anything in your program unless you have
brain cancer or a ruddy brain frequencies. Then I, I wouldn't say that the frequencies would be the
thing that would be probably keeping you awake. I think it'd be the sound and the light that's
probably keeping you awake. So those are the things that I would play with. Okay, I appreciate that.
The sound doesn't, I don't think, well, it's hard to ever hear anything. I do cover up the plug-in
thing, forget what it's called, you know, the, I covered that light up but I wasn't sure I should
cover the rife machine because I didn't want it to overheat. Yeah, you don't want to cover the top
where the air flow goes. You don't want to cover that. I for sure cover the lights on the front
of the machine up. Yeah, okay. Again, I think I've told multiple of you that if I built the machine,
I would not have lights on the front of the machine. Okay, but, yeah, try a few things and see if
that makes a difference. I will let you know that I'm not a light sleeper. You're a heavy sleeper,
it still keeps you up. Yeah, well, I don't know if it is for sure, I just wanted to ask the question.
And that could be that I've been on taxa-tier chemo. Yeah, I don't know if that doesn't. Yeah,
that's possible too. You might want to Google that and see if that's one of the side effects of that.
Okay, thank you for your time and I so appreciate the video blog you're doing. Thank you.
You bet. We had another question come in via chat. It says, how do I know if I should have the
copper zinc ratio test done? Or is this a determination, determination you made at the two-day evaluation?
Well, it is partly determined that the two-day evaluation of copper is a real driver in your
cancer and we put you on a copper homeopath or gave you the copper zinc spray. However,
most people's two-day evaluation was quite some time ago. So I don't know off the top by head
the cost of that copper zinc ratio test. I think it's less than $100 though. So I can find out
in the next day or so and post it on Facebook. So if anybody wants to do that test, I'll look
and up and see what the cost of that test is so that that give you an idea whether it's a value
to you or to do that or not. Okay, any other questions?
Dr. Connors.
Dr. Connors, can you hear me? I can.
Okay, the other very thanksgiving. I suddenly start breaking out with little blisters.
It started out. It looked like kind of like mosquito bite. That was larger than the mosquito bite
and also like they came up with little blisters on my finger and on my hand. Do you have any idea
what those might be? Are they like like a big spot of them or just like what here, what there?
It's occurred on my legs. There's probably about five or six on each one of my legs
and on my arms, there's a couple of my arms. Are they pus filled?
Dr. Connors. Yeah, they are. They have pus in them.
Dr. Connors. Yeah, there's kind of a kind of a, like I said, it's like a mosquito bite.
Dr. Connors. Yeah, pimple comes up on the top of it.
Dr. Connors. Okay, so rashes of any kind, you start asking questions like,
okay, is it topical type dermatitis, meaning that the skin was irritated from something that
irritated it from the outside in and that would be a type of insect bite. Well, it couldn't be that
if you got multiple in an area and another area unless you had multiple spider bites or something
like that, which that's possibility, but probably not if you had if you don't think it that look
like it's quite a bite in a norm. It's just too big for mosquito or anything like that.
Okay. I think they're too far. They're spread apart. They're spread out to, like I said, about
four or five on each of my legs and then my arms as well. Do they itch?
Yes. Okay, so we know there's a histamine reaction going on there then too,
so that you're back to could it be something topical, like am I having a sensitivity to
the laundry detergent and I have a sensitivity to something I'm putting on like a lotion or something
like that. You investigate that piece of soap or something like that and you go, well, I'm
using this laundry detergent or this soap for years. Why would I break out? It's when our body's chemistry
changes a little bit. We could react to things. So that's one thing you'd want to investigate.
Then secondly, you go, okay, is it something from the inside out? So from the inside out,
then you could think of a histamine type reaction to a food. So I'm having a food reaction,
a food sensitivity reaction in my skin. That's not uncommon. So then you have to start
investigated. Did I change anything I eat? Even a brand, so that brand might have a chemical
like a dye in it. It's like red dye number two or something like that. Look and investigate that
or is it my body detoxing something? That's what I was wondering. You know, when he started,
it's probably been three or four weeks ago that we did the review for the genetic review.
Okay, so we weren't able to get the supplements right away. But right away, I started on the
tumouric, really heavily. And then when we got the supplements, the first, after maybe three days,
I can't remember what the reaction was, but I remember, oh, I wonder if this is detox.
Well, then the next week he complained about kidney is having some like a ball ache in his kidneys. So
he increased his water and that passed. The next week he complained about is kidneys, there were
sharp pain there. And so he used cranberry juice, concentrate, and that passed. Okay, so now this,
now this is so I'm wondering, is this the vaccine or what? Yeah, that's what it sounds like.
Either that or he's just a complainer.
So I think it sounds like he's detoxing. So this is what I want to do. I want to look at review
again, what we put about it for. I think what's happening is we're pulling stuff out of his body,
but it's not getting through his liver and his kidneys to get out. So it's coming out as skin.
Okay, so let me look, we're probably pulling too quickly. So it's evidence that number one,
he's got junk that needs to come out. So I didn't want it. That's a nice way of saying you're full
of it, but I didn't want to say that. But number two, it's not coming out in the pathways that we
want it to. So and this gives you back to an example of, you know, is this skin
or a good of detoxification? Yes, the skin is an organ of detoxification. So you go back to things
like, wow, this makes me think of like doing a soda again. Would that be a good, another good way
to take a lot of stress off my kidneys in my liver? Yes, you can see how we have rashes and we don't
think of them as that's where my body's trying to get rid of something that it needs to get out of
it that it's not able to get out through the kidneys and the liver very well. So that's that's
what I would think of. Let me review his things and either I or one of the girls will call you tomorrow,
okay? Okay, thanks. Appreciate your live and help. Oh, you bet. Dr. Cunner's on the life
machine. This is Deb from Ohio. The right machine, oh, newsletter from
to right. Anyway, they were discussing that this one lady says, are, did many people have trouble
discharging the frequencies from their body? Just when she would walk into a room, the light would
turn on. Then when she'd walk out, the light would turn off. And then she'd climb into the car
and it filled with her with her car, um, electronics. See you. And then they,
somebody's the comments were saying that it's because your body's not strong enough to detox those
frequencies? Well, it's, it's really done that. It's that there's people that are so sensitive
to E of F's that they pick up, they pick up frequencies easily and it could discharge like that.
I like somebody who ever, they might be on the phone here or on the call here today, but
I can't remember when that person was in the office, they said that multiple times,
it was a gentleman, I believe, because I think his wife told the staff that he's just super
electromagnetic and when he walks in a room, the light will go on sometimes, you know, like that.
Um, uh, there's, I've had numerous patients that can't wear watches because their watch will stop.
And they'll go get a new battery or do watch and the watch stops.
And the genetic component of that is a specific gene that there's four of the genes in the family
that if you remember going over your genetic piece, it's down, way down at the bottom of the whole
genetic profile. And, uh, people with defects in those genes have issues like that.
So, um, that can be a component with that can be an issue with some people, yes.
But it is specifically an issue with people with, um, uh, with that gene defect.
So, do you, do you, ground yourself? How do you get, uh, discharge that?
Well, you have to, so if you have that gene defect, uh, you know, and it's, there's four
genes in that family and typical, typically those people have, uh, defects on all four of those
genes that have really issues, really bad issues with EMFs. And we have numerous, especially you see
this with Lyme patients, not as much with cancer patients, um, but you see it more with Lyme patients
because people with really bad EMF issues tend to not be able to get rid of biotoxins very well.
So, they get bit with a tick with Lyme disease and they can't get over it.
They're hypersensitive to EMFs. So, with our Lyme patients, it's almost a given. They have a lot of
defects on those genes. They tend to be hypersensitive to EMFs, hypersensitive to biotoxins.
It's not quite as often with cancer patients, but you have to be more diligent with protecting yourself
from EMF, um, uh, influence in your body and that has to do with going back to all the EMF procedures
of making sure you're not, you're turning off your phone when you're not using that,
to using those protector devices on your telephone because you'll get
majority EMFs from your cell phone, cell phone towers. And now this whole 5G thing is going to
just not write scary. At EMF protection in your house and such.
Uh, and then as far as grounding, go back to the grounding thing. So, you're grounding yourself by
going out and standing on the ground. How about your grounding sheets and pillow? Yep. Those are,
those are devices to do that. Okay. One more question. Delight the, um, hammer ball.
You were guys, you were seeing covered up at night with your blankets. Can you also put like a,
um, black t-shirt over it so you, it doesn't interfere with circadian rhythms?
Well, I would prefer a green bay packer t-shirt over it, but it's, that's totally
clear. Not this year at all. Not this year.
Maybe a bear's one this year. Okay. But it'd be okay to cover it with a, with
the, some black that, sorry, come out of it. Yes. Okay. Thank you.
Another question came in. It's a copper zinc test, a typical blood test done by,
um, a real doctor that wasn't the question, but yes, it can be. You just have to ask for it.
So if you go in, if you're going in for a regular physical and you say, could I get a copper zinc,
uh, ratio test done, most of the doctors will go, uh, I don't know. I could look up and see if we have it.
But yes, they should be, it's, it's not a typical lab. So they should be able to run that.
So if you are going in to your oncologist on a regular basis, ask for it, demand it. Say,
I need to get a copper's a gracious serum, copper's a gracious test and see what they say.
Dr. Connors. Uh-huh. Lisa Nagel in New Jersey. How are you? Good.
I have, um, a question. I am using the U.S. enzymes cleanse. I'm, and I am taking that as like my
digestive enzyme like three times a day. I love it. I think it's so wonderful. Um, is so,
could I interrupt you right there? Yeah.
Quick. Yeah. So cleanse I'm does have their patented astrozyme in it.
Um, but it's, it doesn't have a lot of other digestive enzymes in it.
Okay. So if you don't have really a digestive issue really bad, you could use it for your
digestive enzyme. But really cleanse I'm is a product really for your liver more than anything else
because it helps. It's really got all the products in there to help you detoxify. It's helping
liver pathways. Okay. It's got turkey tail mushroom. It's got milk this ill. It's got a whole bunch of
stuff in there. I love cleanse. I take it every day, um, two, three times a day. So I'm with you
too with the cleanse on. Yeah. It's, um, I mean, I had digestive problems leading up to and with the
cancer, but since I've been between my eating and all everything I'm doing and everything, the
digestive system totally, totally calm down and is not an issue. And this product I, so I just want,
okay, so that's not, if I feel like I'm eating a little, you know, too much or something I'll take
a regular digestive enzyme. Yeah. Okay. And um, the other question is how do you do the distance
kinesiology? How do you schedule it? Now, how, like, how do I know what kinesiology is and I know
you did it when I was there, but the distance. So it would, you would do it with someone else or
over my chart or how do you, yeah. So if I told you, I'd have to kill you. So literally, um, we
pull up your chart and literally Michelle and I are there and we literally pray that God gives us
the answers to this test that you are right there and that the answers come from the Holy Spirit
alone and we do kinesiology just like your lady there at the table. Awesome. Okay. We do it right
over the table and um, and I know there are some Christians would say, oh no, that's just voodoo or
something that's like, I don't think it God's eyes, there's, there's time and space and he can give us
those answers anywhere we want if we ask with the right heart. So. Yeah, I agree. Okay. I just want
to make sure. Okay. Thank you so much. So a couple questions came into the chat. What is what's
the best and fastest way to get electrolytes to cure or avoid dehydration? So there's a couple ways.
We have a couple products, OptiBegg, uh, from Zalimogen is a powdered electrolyte product
and the other one from Designed from Health, that's called something electrolytes, which is another
powdered electrolyte product, but you can even take like, drink pickle juice. Yes, pickle juice
has tons of electrolytes in it. So what are electrolytes in the first place? Electrolites are minerals.
So you're getting electrolytes when you're drinking your greens supplement. So do we put a lot of
people on the OptiBegg or on the powdered electrolytes? No, we don't because you're, if you're
drinking, and you have the greens, drink another, put another couple of scoops of greens in for today,
if you want electrolytes, you're getting electrolytes from your greens. And if you really need some
electrolytes, drinking pickle juice has lots of electrolytes. So those are your fastest ways of
getting electrolytes right there. The greens are a good food-based electrolyte, so that's a good,
a good source. The other question that came in, you referenced, Souda's earlier, is having a Souda
an effective cancer treatment and would a long-hot shower do a similar result. A long-hot shower will
not do a similar result. A Souda is the reason why that's effective. It's effective for two
reasons really, for a cancer patient. So number one, if you're going in the Souda and you're
effectively sweating, you are getting out of your pores toxins. So you are using your skin as a
tool of detoxification if you're in there sweating every day. That's number one. Number two,
with a cancer patient, if you're in a good Souda and you're in there and it's hot and you're sweating,
you are raising your core temperature. So you're not raising it a lot, but you might raise it up
to 101 degrees, which is great because you're basically causing a fever state in the body,
which isn't immune stimulant. So that is just what the doctor ordered for a person with cancer. So
a hot shower isn't going to do that. A hot tub is maybe going to raise core temperature
possibly, but there's not going to be any sweaty to the hot tub. Hot shower, you're not going
to really be sweaty to the hot shower. Steam room, well a steam room do that. You have a
club with a steam room, maybe, but the negatives of the steam room is that they're typically connected
just to the water supply of the club, which is fluoride and chlorine. So you're basically breathing in
chlorine and fluoride. That's not good. So I'm not a big fan of steam rooms, even though they're kind
of fun. But it's better off in a sauna or to really your best office sauna. Hot tub can help
raise your core temperature a little bit. If it's hot, but typically hot tub is the water that you
can't tolerate water more than maybe 100 to 103 degrees. So there's no way you're really going to
raise core body temperature up to the temperature of water. So you're not really hot tub's really just
for comfort level and maybe muscle comfort. Not really a cancer treatment. Okay, so I do need to also
get to these questions on this email too. All right, a question is a person is traveling with their
rife and maybe going to Egypt with their rife and how to get it through customs as a medical device.
Okay, so that can be an issue. So I know we have shipped the rife to various countries all over
Russia, Bulgaria, a bunch of different countries. I have not shipped ever to Egypt or any of the
shipped to Israel, but none of the other Middle East countries. So I'm not really sure about their
customs. But one of the things that we were told like rife was that if you're going to
tell the customs agent that it's a medical device, that can be an issue. Because they see a bulb and
then they see a machine. They think it could be emitting radiation or something. And in translation,
a medical device, this could be dangerous. We do not let any radiation emitting devices that are
in our country and you could have issues. If they see a bulb in a machine,
what Mike it's true, I've said just tell them it is just a neon bulb machine. It's
we've always had it gone through. So I don't know that I would recommend say that it's a medical
device because I think that could cause more issues than anything. I think you're better off
just claiming it as a as a neon tube machine. And I might have to think I'll email this person back
with some wordy that might be helpful. So I know that you're on this call. So I'll email you back with
some wordy that might be helpful that Mike and true rife gave us. Next question this person said,
how do I know from by phase a go by muscle mass. We don't know from your phase a go your muscle mass.
The phase a go is an electrical reading of your cell membrane, not of the muscle mass. By that test,
we did there's a way to look at muscle mass. So I'll have to look at your numbers again and I'll see if
we have that data. The next question was last question was when I was there. I was tested
to see if there's supplements. So I'll answer this one on the e-mail too. So so that you get a more
detailed thing. Okay, I'm on beauty to everybody. I have time for what are two more questions.
Can I ask you one question about thinking copper test. I need to repeat the IV gene. What would
be better copper zinc or the IV gene? What would you I don't understand. Well, copper zinc is not
going to tell us, you know, really a picture, a real picture of tumor burden unless we had a previous
copper zinc test. So if you want to really know the direction your cancer's going right now and
we have established a baseline and several follow-ups on your IV gene, I would say the IV gene test
would be the best one to do. But so maybe start the copper zinc ratio test might not be a bad idea to
to get a baseline of that. Okay, thank you. I have a question about colostrum.
Uh-huh. I've had a couple of people within the last month to talk about, you know, building
immune system with, you know, the colostrum. And I wanted to get your thoughts on it.
Obviously I'm concerned because my calcium is high and I don't want to add anything to that
working really hard to get it down. So I'm not a fan of colostrum for pet cancer patients.
If you don't have cancer, colostrum is a great addition. It can be really healing
for your gut. And one of the reasons why it's healing is it's higher IGF1 levels.
So, but remember, go back to some of those other Zoom calls and videos that I've done on IGF1 insulin
growth factor. One, we do not want to raise IGF1 levels if you have cancer.
No. So colostrum is a dodo for cancer patients, typically.
Okay. Very good. Well, thank you. Appreciate it.
Yes. Any other questions?
Hi, Dr. Kevin. Uh, Dr. Connor. It's currently speaking. Thank you.
No, Hurley. What are you doing? I'm doing super. Hi. I'm just wondering, you know, I'm,
thank you for answering my, because I, I want to trouble to Cuba too. Cuba, Cuba is okay to take my
machine too. You know, I, I can't answer that definitively because I've never been to Cuba. I've
never tried to take it into there. You're always dealing whatever you take at your machine into
another country. You're dealing with a human who's making a decision. Yeah. That's the difficult.
You get somebody who didn't eat lunch today and they could be a little hankerous. So, um, it's,
there is that risk factor. We used to do, you know, we used to live in Mexico. We used to do a lot of
work and bringing this stuff across the border in Mexico, doing missionary work and, um, it was
always an issue where, where they were trying to get us to bribe them. And, and I, and I felt for them
because they probably got paid almost nothing to do their job, but knowing that they're going to make
money on bribe. But as the poor missionary, we didn't have anybody to give anybody money for
bribes. I just played stupid all the time to the point where they got so disgusted with me that they
let me go by. So, um, right. And my, my, my fear at any of that is that if they think they could
make money off of the heed that you really did, and they think there's value that they could resell it,
I'd hate to have them confiscated. In this case, what, what's the solution? Because basically,
I want to, you know, I'm from Europe and I'm traveling, you know, I don't, I don't know. And I just,
I want to use my machine. I want to heal, you know, this. So, how long are you going to be, uh,
this trip? I'm planning to go to Cuba at least two weeks, but, but sometimes I'm going to Europe for
month. Well, I don't think you're going to trouble at Europe. Um, we've not had any issues with Europe.
We've had numerous patients from European countries bring their machine back with them, no problem.
Um, so, so the computer put it into the carry on and the machine can be put into the bigger.
Sure. You could put the machine in your carry on, the computer, the carry on, you could put the
involvement in your, in your, in your check luggage. And I don't think you're going to even get
questioned. But, uh, but going into, to Cuba, I think that might, that could be an issue. So, um,
I just don't know how stricter lacks they are with, with whatever you bring into that country.
So, I've not had anybody go there before. Oh, really? Because I want to get some, some sunshine,
you know, I'm living in Canada. Why don't you, you know, see, can I go with you?
Yes, please, bring your rifle machine. Okay. Feel.
And, you know, we can, I really, really, uh, and I have another question, you know, I, I made
cocktail animal on a lot before and I really like it. How many I should, I should make, because I
make usually ones, should I make two, but it makes, it keeps me off. You know, I would just do, right
now I would do one. Um, the only, the, if you are having trouble, uh, having a bowel movement,
and you feel like you're not getting everything out, then it's okay to do another one a little later
in the morning. Um, but many times people have trouble with the caffeine, keep you a little
wake if they do it after three o'clock. Yes. So, um, I would try to get it done before that if you're
going to do a second or third one. I'm sorry, I am a very, I think, what person, you know, I,
I just want to ask something, uh, okay. So, when you have a coffee anymore, I'm, I'm talking generally,
okay? And, uh, you look at the toilet, I look at the toilet. There are a little, there are little,
I think they have little fat yellow things. Is this normal? I think maybe, maybe it's must be the
bio, the fat coming out. Uh, no, no, by the time, so what's going to come out in the coffee
edema is in your, uh, sigmoid colon rectal area. Uh, you're not going to, by doing the coffee
edema, you're not accelerating peristalsis. So what is in the, the first part of the small intestine,
the only way what's in the first part of the small intestine, or in the small intestine at all,
which is 20 feet long, it, anyway, the only way that is going to get into the toilet from a coffee
edema is when the peristalsis takes place. We need contraction of the smooth muscle of the intestines
that's going to push it through. A coffee edema will not open up the intestines and dump everything out
of the intestines. So what, what you see in the toilet after you do a coffee edema was in the descending
colon. That is the large, the last couple feet of the larger intestine. That's all you're going to
get to come out. The purpose of the coffee edema is not necessarily to constipate a person, though
if I have constipation due to feces that is, that is, that is kind of, um, in a stasis mode in
last part of my larger intestine, that will help open it up and help pull that out.
But the purpose of the coffee edema is to stimulate the vagus nerve, that cranial nerve,
tend that resides on the rectal area in a sigmoid colon to stimulate the, to stimulate that
here a sympathetic reaction, which is from cranial nerve, tend from the vagal nerve that will stimulate
the detoxification pathways in the liver. So bottom line coffee edema's purpose is to help stimulate
liver detoxification. It will not pull out pieces of fat and stuff. If you have fat that is undigested,
sitting in the, the last part of the large intestine, we have a gallbladder issue.
Oh yeah, because I do. I think I, in this case, I, I always, always, almost always, have little,
little yellowish things on the top of, so it must be fat.
It's still, just because it's floating, it doesn't mean it's fat. You can see things in your feces
that, that, that if, if you had a solid ball movement, it would, it would be hidden in your, in the
solid ball movement, but it's, since you are added coffee into the rectal area, it kind of liquefied
what you had in the, in the cola there, and it's going to come out in particles that would normally
be formed into a solid ball movement. So you're going to see particles of food, what you ate,
like, you know, that didn't get completely digested and broken down. It's not a comma that people see
like corn, because it's harder to digest, some things that are harder to digest.
Or they say piece of, piece of food. Dr. Connor, and I have an other last question, because I do,
two results is still spending, spending, spending, sorry, there is one of the DNA results,
and I got an email here, I don't know what, what to do with it, that I think I wrote it on my email.
Do I need to get, permit to get to the DNA results test?
Okay, sure. Yeah, I will have Ed or Ashley reach out to you about that tomorrow, the email,
so that I'll see if, if you're already registered or not, or that if you just give them permission,
they could register you. So we'll get that taken care of. Okay, thank you. And I don't have
the thermal camera, I don't have anything back. Okay, so we'll look at that email, we'll make sure
we get all those questions answered for you. Okay, okay, I don't think so, I wrote the thermal camera
address, so thank you very much. Thank you. Oh, you bet. Are you, are you okay? Is it cold there?
Is it cold here? Is that what you said? Oh, no, it was like 12 today.
It's 12 degrees. Yeah, it's cold. Yeah, it's cold. So thank you again and bless everyone.
Oh, thank you so much. We love you. Please pray for me. Okay, I'm trading for sure. Thank you.
All right, I think we better call it. It's we've been at 50 minutes today, so
we're always going to listen to this video if we get too much longer. And please email your questions
in for next week and continue to use the Facebook. So thanks everybody. Thank you. Thank you, Dr.
Connors. Hi, I know. Bye.